have made buddha baker the highest paid
safety when we talk about new money i
always roll my eyes when i see these
initial reports because what happens is
the information merchants will say
whatever the agent tells them to say
otherwise they ain't getting it and four
years 59 million 33 million guaranteed
best contract ever for safety well he
still had a year left on his prior deal
it's really a 12 million dollar per year
deal over five years not nearly 15
million per year over four and that 33
million guaranteed isn't fully
guaranteed and fully guaranteed doesn't
even mean fully guaranteed as we're
learning in the earl thomas case it's
guaranteed for skill injury or cap we
don't know how much of the 33 million is
guaranteed for skill injury and cap but
still he comes out of nowhere as the
highest paid safety in terms of new
money and uh you know it was a surprise
nobody knew there was no hold in there
was no reporting there was no jostling
there was nothing they had him under
contract for one more year they could
have waited they're going to have some
guys they have to pay coming up in the
not too distant future with kyler murray
now he's still two years away but you
got a plan for that and you've got
deandre hopkins they give this big money
to buda baker at a time when it's clear
deandre hopkins wants his
a little awkward situation potentially
in arizona chris well yes i mean i think
they'll be able to balance it all when
all said and done i mean i would
hopefully be i would like to think
they're thinking about the de'andre
hopkins thing there and realize that
this could be you know coming down the
road or they're gonna have to deal with
it at some point i know the buddha baker
thing you know shocked some people out
there i understand that but i think the
big thing i would say is you know the
first thing is
just like joey bosa with the chargers
right where we talk about man is he
really the best defensive player in
football i mean nobody really says he's
the best no you're right he's not he's
not the best but you know he's in that
conversation as we always talk about for
the top five top six that kind of guy
and we know when one of those guys comes
up as a free agent or gets a new deal
they usually become the richest at their
position and when it's all said and done
it's an incredibly important position
this day and age in the nfl i mean there
is great value with these safety hybrid
players like buddha baker he's a lot
like a honey badger or a jamaal adams or
derwin james where they they they do a
lot around him and his talents on that
defense he can cover the george kittles
of the world and yet he can tackle the
matte breeders of the world in space uh
or take on guys and blockers that way so
he's got a very
important skill set this day and age in
the nfl with how much you know teams are
multiple on offense and tight ends can
be receivers and you know running backs
can be receivers and of course good
running backs and all those things so
he's in that conversation is he as good
as darwin james or jamal adams or justin
simmons of the denver broncos or honey
badger no i don't think he is but he's a
really damn good player and i think from
that point you know he's that next group
of guys where you could say he's the
best after those names we just named you
know eddie jackson was the highest paid
safety in football until yesterday i
don't think anybody was sitting here
going eddie jackson's the best safety in
football for the chicago bears so
i guess we shouldn't be shocked is what
i'm saying
it's all about timing it's all about
getting a guy while he's ascending right
not while he's plateaued or descending
right but you know there are these other
names and and it's funny buddha baker
gets the contract he's not trending on
twitter it's jamal adams who's trending
because it raises the bar
for him now look he already wanted more
than 15 million he reportedly is
thinking about 20. i don't know that
he's going to get to 20 unless he waits
for the market to otherwise get closer
to 20 but it does raise that bar for
adams for anthony harris who's playing
under his franchise tag in minnesota
this year with no long-term deal and the
vikings could tag him again next year to
20 bump justin simmons same deal in
denver playing under the franchise tag
and the broncos are going to have to
figure out what to do and you know maybe
one of these guys sneaks through to the
open market it'll be interesting to see
what a top level safety would get on the
open market right out of the gates
because if buddha baker is getting
almost 15 million a year in new money
yeah while still under contract for one
more year with his current team and they
could franchise tag him and they could
do all these other things to keep him
around what does that guy who steps onto
the market the first day of free agency
potentially get and between anthony
harris and justin simmons there's a
chance one of them's gonna do it next
year yeah i would think one of them
because yeah i don't think we're going
to see jamal adams or derwen james ever
hit that you know i i would i would have
a hard time thinking justin simmons does
either we'll see what the vikings do you
know they have another safety they're
paying there and harrison smith you know
a lot of money so you don't want to you
know put too much money to one position
but you're right this certainly has
raised the bar
and
i expect you know jamal adams to be that
guy yeah this helps him but i kind of
expect jamal adams to be that like
george kiddo guy that we just saw with
contracts where he kind of blows the
rest of the safety contracts out of the
water a little bit he sets himself apart
like where we saw julio jones like hey
wide receiver was 18 million and all of
a sudden he got 22 million a year and
really moved the bar i think jamal adams
is going to be that type of talent which
then will lead it up for derwin james
but buda baker is a hell of a football
player he really is mike i mean he was
when this contract happened last night
and i knew we were going to talk about
the show i turned on film yesterday and
sat there and watched buddha baker for
about 30 or 40 minutes and just went
damn you know he's all over the place he
really is he's a ball hawk he's got a
lot of honey badger-ish type you know
style of play about them we just don't
hear about them arizona's not worth the
damn lately their defense has stunk and
they don't have household names that way
but uh he is a really damn good player
and i think very worthy of this contract
with the way the nfl works right now
yeah and uh look that that's the way it
goes and there are going to be guys that
aren't on the radar screen as the next
up for getting the big contract who just
happened to get it because of
circumstance timing and everything else
that goes into it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports